la présidente la commission
merci monsieur le Président en
application de l'article 46 bis alinéa 2
du règlement la Commission demande un
examen séparé de l'amendement 21 32 des
rapports et en application de l'article
44 à 6 de règlement nous demandons
également la priorité d'examen de votre
sur cette amendement merci monsieur le
ministre
sagesse donc il y a pas d'opposition du
gouvernement donc la priorité est
ordonnée
il y a une demande de priorité sur
l'amendement
2132 de la part de la Commission afin
qu'il soit mis au voie en premier avant
l'ensemble des amendements de l'article
donc il est dans l'alliance le 2132 de
la Commission
c'est en cours de distribution
on attend on attend la distribution
merci monsieur le Président rappelle au
règlement s'il vous plaît selon
l'article 46 bis vous demandez de bien
vouloir nous laisser une petite minute
pour prendre
non seulement conscience on va dire des
conséquences que la présidente de la
commission vient d'annoncer en donnant
priorité sur un amendement et donc avec
les conséquences que cela et
bouleversant l'ordre de l'examen des
amendements prévus est-ce que vous
voulez bien rappeler excusez-moi
pouvez-vous rappeler ou madame la
Présidente pour vous rappeler ce que la
Commission propose sur l'ordre d'examen
des amendements s'il vous plaît alors
moi j'étais saisi d'une demande de
priorité sur l'amendement 2132 de la
commission qui a dû être en cours de
distribution
donc alors madame la présentation oui
merci merci monsieur le Président bon on
n'a pas l'amendement mais on voit bien
ce qui est ce qu'on essaye de de tramer
en proposant cette cette priorité sur
cet amendement de 1132 qui arrive quand
même loin dans l'examen de cet article 9
donc sur la base de ce que vient de dire
ma collègue nous demandons parce que
nous avons besoin de retravailler
puisque nous avions un certain nombre
d'amendements qui précédait cet
amendement de Monsieur Savary nous
demandons une suspension de saison de
séance car nous avons besoin nous aussi
de travailler de réfléchir à une à une
un autre au développement
alors si je peux terminer si je peux
terminer
ma phrase simplement donc je le redis
demandez une suspension de séance pour
permettre à mon groupe de pouvoir
travailler bah oui mais écoutez vous
avez vu aussi tuer la demande de 1132
dans la dans la liasse vous avez vu le
nombre d'amendements que nous avons et
qui précède cet amendement donc nous
avons besoin de travailler nous sommes
des gens sérieux et responsables et nous
avons besoin de travailler donc
suspension de séance
merci ma présidente le président Gontard
oui merci un rappel un règlement sur
l'article 44 bis de la même manière et
ce qui a été dit je demandais également
à voir un peu de temps pour conserver
organise effectivement on voit bien là
la manipulation mais le fait de faire
remonter cette cette amendement
forcément ça nous déstabilise il faut
bien qu'on se réorganise bah oui si
c'est une c'est une réalité franchement
je sais pas comment vous arrivez vous
m'expliquerez comment vous arrivez à
travailler dans ces conditions là mais
je pense que franchement ça manque un
petit peu de sérieux quand même ça
manque un petit peu de sérieux donc
c'est très bien on agite l'article 38 on
agite ça mais quand même ça manque
réellement de sérieux donc moi je
demande à ce qu'on est une suspension de
séance qu'on puisse s'organiser et qu'on
puisse repartir sur des basses saines
comme on vient de le faire jusqu'à
présent merci et à monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président canner
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
depuis quelques heures même quelques
jours vous nous accusez de toutes les
turpitudes
de toutes les turpitudes voire même de
je ne sais pas quoi
mélenchonisation c'est cela
[Musique]
je vous le dis très simplement
merci d'être finalement en conformité
avec le travail qui doit se poursuivre
au Sénat sur l'examen de ce projet de
loi
ne soyez pas
des loyaux vis-à-vis de votre position
mais oui vous êtes
déloyaux puisque un travail a été fait
d'ordonnancement de nos amendements et
manifestement vous voulez couper court à
ce travail par cette priorisation donc
elle est potentiellement bien sûr tout à
fait réglementaire et légal je dis
simplement que vous contribuez
manifestement par ce type de manœuvre
non pas finalement à de l'obstruction
mais à du sabotage d'un bon travail
parlementaire
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
alors mes chers collègues
s'il vous plaît un petit peu d'attention
je vais accorder cinq minutes de
suspension de séance
attendez attendez attendez mais avant je
voudrais préciser je vous repréciser un
petit peu les choses donc j'ai été saisi
d'une priorité d'une demande de priorité
de la part la Commission le gouvernement
a donné un avis de sagesse et j'ai donc
ordonné cette priorité par ailleurs en
application de l'article 46 bis alinéa 2
du règlement je suis saisi d'une demande
de la commission d'examen séparés sous
amendement 2132 l'article 9 donc je dois
consulter le Sénat sur cette demande
donc qui est pour cet examen séparé
qui est contre
donc la demande d'examen séparée est
adoptée je voudrais vous préciser avant
la suspension de séance ce que
l'adoption de cet amendement ferait
tomber comme autres amendements
pour que pour que les choses soient très
claires
ça ferait tomber à peu près une
soixantaine d'amendements
attendez
vous permettez
si vous voulez travailler sérieusement
président en caner c'est le président
canner si vous voulez travailler
sérieusement faut quand même écouter ce
sinon vous allez vous demander après ce
qui va se passer donc l'adoption de
l'amendement 2132 ferait tomber les
amendements identiques de suppression
d'articles du 301 au 3790
ainsi que les amendements 44
430 43
3352 3136 et 3922
nous reprendrions à ce moment-là la
discussion à l'amendement 3308 est-ce
que j'ai été clair
madame de La Gontrie
monsieur le Président merci pour me
rappeler le règlement fondé sur le 46
bis l'article 46 bisit très clairement
les amendements doivent être examinés
par premièrement les amendements de
suppression et ensuite les autres
amendements donc vous venez énoncer et
je vous en remercie l'ordre d'examen des
amendements et vous avez annoncé
également que cela ferait tomber les
amendements qui pourtant sont des
amendements de suppression il y a donc à
mon sens une distorsion par rapport à
l'application
normale du règlement
Roger caoutchi n'a pas besoin de secouer
la tête en disant non je le connais
depuis tellement longtemps que je
connais sa façon de fonctionner
sachant que sachant que nous abordons
aussi la question délicate et je suggère
à la droite du Sénat d'être attentive à
ce point de la clarté de la sincérité du
débat parlementaire que nous allons
contester devant le Conseil
constitutionnel pourquoi
l'amendement vient des distribuer grâce
à la diligence de la science et nous
pouvons les en remercier car il n'était
même pas dans l'allias distribuée c'est
à dire que nous n'avons aucune
visibilité sur le périmètre de la
discussion et nous pouvons nous étonner
qu'un amendement à la Linéa 4 de
l'article 9 fasse tomber des amendements
de suppression donc sur ce point là nous
nous opposons à cette demande de
réorganisation du débat et par ailleurs
monsieur le Président 5 minutes de
suspension c'est bien de bien vouloir
nous accorder une suspension puisque
vous seul pouvez en décider mais si nous
voulons que les travaux se fassent dans
des conditions correctes et n'atteignent
pas à l'excès la clarté la sincérité du
bas je pense que 30 minutes est plus
raisonnable
chers collègues chers collègues attendez
mes chers collègues par rapport je
réponds je réponds excusez-moi président
Laurent je réponds sur le règlement ce
que vous avez cité c'est sauf décision
du Sénat sur proposition de la
Commission saisie au fond et là il y a
une proposition de la Commission saisie
au fond et donc c'est une pratique
constante dans notre assemblée de
pratiquer de cette façon là donc il y a
pas il y a pas d'ambiguïté sur le il y a
pas d'ambiguïté sur le règlement je l'ai
revu il y a aucune ambiguïté sur ce
point là
écoutez moi je veux je veux bien
suspendre la séance pour 10 minutes
compte tenu du sujet
donc je suis sport la séance pour 10
minutes la séance est suspendue
[Musique]